wir sind echte dramen die sich derzeit
an verschiedenen orten unserer welt
abspielen sie alle zeigen dass die
klimakrise bereits jetzt unser leben und
unseren alltag extrem beeinflusst doch
es wird noch schlimmer kommen
das zeigt jetzt eine aktuelle studie
eines us forschungsteams demnach könnte
das worst-case-szenario scp 8.5 des
weltklimarates bittere realität werden
doch an dieses andere deutlich wärmere
klima sind wir menschen nicht angepasst
klicks um science and future heute aus
augsburg vom klima camp gibt es dreimal
pro woche also bei klicks und science
and future spannendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen und heute
unterstützen mich aktivistinnen und
aktivisten vom klima camp aus augsburg
die hier schon mehr als 40 tage
ausharren um zumindest aus burg zur
einhaltung seines co2 budgets zu
motivieren die vergangenen tage waren
extrem heiß und weltweit wurden kratzer
hitze rekorde gebrochen
zum beispiel am persischen golf wo die
temperaturen in manchen städten bei zehn
grad über dem durchschnitt für diese
jahreszeit lagen bagdad 52 grad damaskus
46 grad selbst für gesunde menschen
können temperaturen um die 50 grad
gefährlich werden
es ist wirklich eine dramatische hitze
klimakatastrophe die sich bereits jetzt
quasi vor unserer haustür abspielt und
die uns zeigt dass die klimakrise
bereits jetzt in vollem gange ist immer
mehr regionen weltweit werden in zukunft
wohl durch solch hohe temperaturen nicht
mehr bewohnbar sein
studien zufolge könnte es bereits in 50
jahren so weit sein dass ein drittel der
menschheit von diesem problem betroffen
ist ihre heimat kann dann durch den
klimawandel unbewohnbar werden überall
auf der erde spielen sich dramen ab und
kaum jemand schenkt diesen
aufmerksamkeit in russland ist seit
anfang diesen jahres 2020 nach angaben
von greenpeace eine fläche von knapp 20
millionen hektar durch waldbrände
zerstört worden
das muss man sich mal vorstellen das ist
mehr als die hälfte der fläche
deutschlands
eine fatale waldbrandkatastrophe könnte
es in diesem jahr auch wiederum im
amazonasgebiet geben möglicherweise
sogar noch
schlimmer als in dramatischen
vergangenen jahr 2019 dann bereits das
war eine riesige ökologische katastrophe
geschah die erschreckenden bilder gingen
um die welt und der rauch war sogar vom
weltall aus zu sehen selbst die
millionenmetropole sao paulo die 2000
kilometer entfernt liegt wo dem august
2009 10 vom rauch verdunkelt satelliten
aufnahmen haben jetzt offenbart dass
allein im juni 2020 knapp 2000 250
brände wüteten
das sind knapp 20 prozent mehr als im
juni des vergangenen jahres
außerdem wurde im monat juni auch die
höchste brandrat ist insgesamt 13 jahren
festgestellt im juli wurden allein in
brasilien 7000 feuer gezählt
ganz abgesehen davon dass ihr ganze
landschaften zerstört werden und somit
auch die heimat vieler tier und
pflanzenarten bedroht ist sind die
brände auch für das klima eine einzige
katastrophe
dadurch hat sich die erde nur noch
weiter auf bei den bränden wird
kohlenstoffdioxid frei das dann in die
atmosphäre gelangt die
weltwetterorganisation wmo verweist
ausserdem auch auf die hohen
temperaturen nördlich des polarkreises
in die mittlerweile seit wochen anhalten
werden hierbei klicks zum future darüber
berichtet dass es in diesem jahr 2020
eine traurige premiere gab und zwar
wurden in dieser region das erste mal
regt die rekordmarke von 38 grad celsius
geklagt in sibirien town die
permafrostböden auf und auch dadurch
wird co2 und methan frei dass verstärkt
den treibhauseffekt nochmal auch der
arktis geht es so schlecht wie nie die
ausdehnung des arktischen meereis war im
juli auf dem niedrigsten stand seit
beginn der messungen gesunken
viele hatten gehofft dass die korona
pandemie neben dem ganzen schrecken den
sie mitbringt wenigen der
klimaentwicklung ein stück weit zu gute
kommt tatsächlich sind die
treibhausgasemissionen weltweit als
folge dessen gesunken
denn nicht nur der autoverkehr sondern
auch der flugverkehr und vor allem die
industrieproduktion gingen zurück doch
viele fachleute warnen davor jetzt
anzunehmen dass die klimakrise dadurch
entschärft werden könnte eine aktuelle
studie amerikanischer fachleute macht
das ganze ausmaß deutlich demnach
steuern wir in sachen klima
entwicklungen geradewegs auf das worst
case szenario zu konkreteste jede von
dem so genannten worst case szenario scp
8.5 das vom weltklimarat entwickelt
wurde
die forschenden vom intergovernmental
panel on climate change ic hatten
bereits vor 15 jahren also 2005
verschiedene szenarien ausgetüftelt um
damit verschiedene klimaschutzmaßnahmen
und entwicklungen der wirtschaft zu
illustrieren
die abkürzung steht für repräsentativ
concentration pathways und die zahl
dahinter steht für den klima antrieb
oder auch strahlungs antrieb die
wissenschaft kann damit die änderungen
in der atmosphäre und die veränderung
der energiebilanz der erde vergleich
beim essen beeinflusst werden dieser
faktoren übrigens durch treibhausgase
sohle und auch die veränderungen an der
erdoberfläche
damit sich die temperaturen auf der erde
nicht verändern müsste es eine art
gleichgewicht geben zwischen der
infrarot strahlung die von der erde
abgestrahlt wird und der einfallenden
sonnenstrahlung wäre die zahl also bei 0
würde sich also nichts verändern wäre es
ein negativer wert wird es auf der erde
kühler werden fest steht aber die
temperatur auf der erde verändert sich
weil hier ein ungleichgewicht besteht
dass er arbeitete worst case szenario
hat die zahl 8.5 was also angibt wie
viel zusätzlichen strahlungs antrieb
also treibhauswirkung die erde bis 2100
bekommen wird und das bei mehr oder
weniger starken klimaschutz maßnahmen
die durchgeführt werden das 8.5 steht
also für den zusätzen strahlungs antrieb
von 8,5 watt pro quadratmeter bis zum
jahr 2100
rechnet man diesen pc wert von 8.5 um
dann kommt man auf das ergebnis dass
sich die erde in den kommenden 100
jahren um 3,3 bis 5,4 grad erwärmen wird
für forschungsteams weltweit ist die
arbeit mit solchen szenarien super
wichtig denn mit ihrer hilfe können die
fachleute prognosen zu den klimafolgen
abgeben das os forschungsteam um den
klimaforscher christopher schreiben hat
jetzt 15 jahre nachdem diese szenarien
geboren wurden eine bilanz gezogen
die große frage die die fachleute klären
wollten lautet welchem szenario kommen
die bisherigen und die zukünftigen
treibhaus emissionen am nächsten und wie
genau ist stand der dinge des weltweiten
klima kurses dafür analysierten die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zunächst den strahlungs antrieb der
emission vom jahr 2005 bis heute
doch auch die bisherigen
klimaschutzpläne der staaten wurden in
ihrer analyse mit einbezogen das
ergebnis der untersuchung ist wenn nicht
dann dazu schreibt das forschungsteam
von den szenarien stimmt 8.5 am besten
mit den kumulativen co2 emissionen von
2005 bis 2020 über ein
die abweichung ist geringer als 1
prozent dieses szenario basiert auf der
annahme dass die wirtschaft weltweit so
weitermacht wie auch in der
vergangenheit
dies bringt einen hohen energieverbrauch
mit sich der verein über fossile
brennstoffe gedeckt wird demnach wird
das szenario 8.5 also immer
realistischer und damit auch eine
erwärmung der erde bis zum jahr 2100 20
von 3,3 bis 5,4 grad
das macht eine sache ganz deutlich
nämlich dass wir nicht nur in der
vergangenheit viel zu wenig getan haben
sondern dass wir auch derzeit zu wenig
in sachen klimaschutz tun außerdem auch
dass die klimaschutzbemühungen in der
zukunft nicht ausreichend sind nach
angaben des us forschungsdienst machen
sich die klimaschutzmaßnahmen die auf
der pariser konferenz vor fünf jahren
beschlossen wurden zwar bemerkbar
doch auch diese reichen nicht aus um an
das nichts besseres szenario zu gelangen
die rede ist hier von dem szenario sc
4.5 einen gemäßigten szenario um dieses
zu erreichen müssten wir der aktuellen
studie zufolge 385 gigatonnen co2
weniger ausstoßen als man es in den
bisherigen emotions prognosen annimmt
voraussetzungen dafür wäre natürlich
dass sich die staaten auch an ihre
versprochenen verpflichtungen halten
werden
und auch das ist noch längst nicht
gesagt nicht eingerechnet sind hierbei
rückkopplungen im klimasystem wie in der
arktis gemeint sind waldbrände oder auch
das abtauen des permafrosts was dazu
führt dass weitere treibhausgase
ausgestoßen werden dazu sagt christa
verschwörung vom woods hole research
center diese rückkopplung drücken die
prognosen weiter in richtung der von atp
85 repräsentierten emissionen und weg
vom gemäßigten szenario sc 4.5 in ihrer
aktuellen analyse schauen die
forschenden aber noch ein stück weiter
in die zukunft mit anwendung der
bisherigen klimaschutzbemühungen
würden wir im jahr 2050 sogar noch ein
bisschen mehr an ausstieg 8.5
zusammengefasst kann man also sagen dass
das worst case szenario am besten zum
aktuellen status quo und dem weltweiten
kurs in sachen klimaschutz passt mit dem
scp 8.5 szenario kann man nach ansicht
des us forschungsteams also die
klimaentwicklung der kommenden 30 jahre
bis zum jahr 2050 am besten beschreiben
und so fordern die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dieses szenario ernst zu nehmen es als
irreführend oder alarmistisch zu
bezeichnen sei realitätsfremd und der
situation nicht angemessen
dazu heißt es als fazit in der studie
mit diesem szenario stimmen nicht nur
die kumulativen historischen emissionen
am besten über einen alibi aktion fünf
pass auch am besten zu den für 2050 auf
basis der aktuellen klimaschutz
entscheidung prognostizierten
bedingungen gerade für die
kürzerfristigen prognosen bis mitte des
jahrhunderts ist atp 85 die
realistischste wahrheit wenn es dieses
szenario noch nicht gäbe müssten wir es
erschaffen die studie von us
wissenschaftler christopher schwalm und
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen wird
derzeit weltweit diskutiert elmar
kriegler vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung pik jedenfalls
warnt in einem interview mit dem
deutschlandfunk dazu deutlich mehr für
das klima zu tun als bisher
dieses sehr pessimistisches szenario ist
zwar in den letzten zehn jahren
realisiert worden weil sehr viele
kohlekraftwerke aufgebaut worden sind
aber angesichts von trends wie
zunehmender nutzung erneuerbarer
energien und auch zunehmend stärker
werdende klima politik nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in anderen
bereichen der welt stehen die zeichen
gut dass es nicht ganz so schlimm kommen
wird allerdings muss man sagen dass
zwischen dem schlimmsten fall und
schlimm auch nur ein gradueller
unterschied ist wenn es statt fünf grad
in 2100 dann 3,5 grad werden und das ist
das was wir sehen wenn wir die
gegenwärtigen trends fortschreiben auch
in der klimapolitik dann ist das auch
noch ein massiver klimawandel und sehr
schlimm
demnach würde uns eine erwärmung von nur
drei grad das leben schwer machen
und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes die
folgen sind stürme fluten dürren und
hochtemperatur ereignisse die in den
verschiedenen regionen dieser erde
unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt sein
werden dazu elmar kriegler vom pk im
deutschlandfunk interview
es wird zu einer massiven veränderung
unserer umwelt und unseres klimas kommt
was wir als menschheit mit vielen
konsequenzen zu bezahlen haben weil wir
eben an dieses andere klima nicht
angepasst sind sondern an das heutige
klima wir dürfen also keine zeit
verlieren also unterstützt uns hier beim
klima camp in augsburg wir setzen hier
vielleicht nur ein zeichen aber umso
mehr mitmachen desto mehr können wir
hier in deutschland europa und weltweit
bewirken dem kann ich mich nur
anschließen denn diese menschen hier
setzten sich nicht für eine ideologie
einen sondern für die umsetzung der
erkenntnisse der wissenschaft eigentlich
traurig dass nicht mal eine
stadtregierung mit beteiligung der
grünen hier in augsburg dazu in der lage
ist in diesem sinne bis dann bleib dran